هذه الصور والمشاهد لقصف الطيران الحربي
في الخرطوم حيث ما زالت الاشتباكات مستمره
حتى هذه اللحظه وكنا نشرنا لكم فيديو
لانتشار قوات من الجيش السوداني في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم حيث تتركز حده
الاشتباكات في وسط العاصمه الخرطوم وكما
يؤكد ايضا شبكه الصحفيين المتواجدين في
الخرطوم وايضا شبكه مراسله العربيه الان
هذه هذا الفيديو الذي نعرضه لكم هو مشاهد
لقصف نفذته مروحيات الجيش في الخرطوم اذا
ما زال الوضع على حاله ورغم اعلان هذه
الهدنه التي من المفترض ان تنتهي في غضون
الساعات المقبله ورغم ان الوضع يشهد هدنه
ولكن حتى هذه الساعه هناك خروقات عده وكما
نتابع هذا دخان الاسود الذي يتصاعد هناك
انتشار مكثف
للطيران الحربي من قبل مروحيات الجيش
السوداني في وسط العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم هذه المشاهد نعرضها لكم اول باول
وننقل لكم ايضا الصوره في ظل هذا الوضع
كله نتحدث عن حركه نزوح كبيره من العاصمه
السودانيه الى ولايات سودانيه اخرى وايضا
هناك الكثير ما زالوا عالقين وايضا ما
زالوا ينتظرون للخروج وسط الحدود عبر
الحدود الى بلدان المجاوره خصوصا افريقيه
منها نتحدث الى تشاد لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات